[Music]
let's go out to San Antonio Tas and talk
to Salem Witch Trials what's up
Salem how's it going can you hear me
yeah we're balling dude what's up it's
awesome to talk to you you too man got
got a little bit of nerves about it I
don't do this sort of thing often but I
have my reasons that I need to call many
of the other shows like the Ken Coleman
show on Entre leadership and and so I
think this is important I started with
this one here
ground to be well enough to do those
other things I want to do in life I'm
grateful man what's
up uh I didn't frame it as a question
but I'll go and just go back to what I
submitted and start there read that off
to you really quickly G and I don't see
the original question so I'll be hearing
it new just brought it up so I can read
it to you um so I've said overwhelmed
with being overworked finding work life
balance achieving growth and progress in
a lot of areas executive dysfunction
struggling to make time for the gym uh
relational connection and growth
effective parenting finding Community
solving other deficits uh it's all
making it difficult to sympathize with
my fiance about her not completing tasks
and carrying uh some more of the burden
I feel like I'm mostly
shouldering uh please advise so are you
a veteran uh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh man so I can expand on a lot of
it um and this I mean if there was room
for it could turn into a whole hour long
two hour long conversation but yeah yeah
yeah I try to be concise no I appreciate
that that's I heard it in your language
um
man are you still in um I'm part-time
now part-timer
okay tell me about who you were before
you went
in before I went in initially
um I mean I
was I don't know I I had a lot time
doing a lot of things that I never
planned on doing that I never really had
a passion for and that's just been
the the kind of pattern for my life okay
there's been
um a whole lot
of disappointment when pursuing things
that I thought would be greater and
bigger I tried to do Socom stuff didn't
didn't cut it out I didn't cut it excuse
me I didn't um didn't make it wasn't
good enough for a lot of things I wanted
to try to do uh I hate that it's the
theme um but I'm still doing what I got
to do in order to survive in order to
get by and and try and push towards
thriving rather than just making it I I
want to be doing things I have passion
for and uh I've spent the better part of
the last year um taking in more wisdom
and knowledge and
adopting uh greater ideals and
philosophies and ideologies so on so
forth than I've ever spent any of my
time in my life before uh to try and
prepare to be this person this man that
I want to be and have the life I want to
lead
um so there's a lot of Failure to Launch
yeah yeah yeah um
um who in the world told you growing up
that you
suck me no you that that's the that's
that's absolutely the the the message
that's the tick or tape under your life
that's that's the voice you pipe into
your own head every day but you got that
from
somebody who told you that if if you
would just you got to go you need to do
this or who told you that I don't have
uh I didn't grow up with a lot of strong
consistent models to follow okay um home
life chaos was yeah I mean there was a
lot of moving around it was a single mom
home okay there you go that's hey that's
all I need to know that's all I need to
know where's Dad where was Dad gone at
6 and do you believe me when I tell you
that there's a seven-year-old little boy
in there combing his hair with an
exhausted scattered mom trying to keep
everything together yeah quietly asking
himself what was so bad about me the dad
left what the hell was so bad with me
that dad didn't want to be
around I never really spent a lot of
time thinking about that I know you
haven't here's the deal think hold on
you spent a bunch of time and a bunch of
energy desperately looking for models to
fill to answer that
question and you chase it and you either
get it and you realize that your body
just moves the Finish Line it's not
enough or you chase it and you don't get
it and you go that's if I had a gotten
it that would have answered that
question I would have been
enough and here's my promise to
you from my guts
brother until you deal with that
seven-year-old little boy you will chase
you'll be amazing you'll start winning
things you'll make money you'll have a
good
job and your insides will be as Hollow
as the inside of a
basketball
yeah cuz you saw a soldier and you're
like that's that's that will make that
dad of mine be proud even if he never
sees me there you
go and it breaks my heart to say this
because I have a 13-year-old little boy
and I can't
imagine leaving
him but that call is not going to
come yeah well we've we've had our come
to Jesus moment it was uh when I was
becoming a father I decided it was
necessary to
uh for I spent a lot of time throughout
my teens in church uh praying to God
that I forgave him and uh I I realized I
think four or five years ago I think
four yeah about four years ago um that I
never told him that I forgave him and I
think so I initiated who whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa homie what do you have to forgive
your dad
for I think I I needed to do it for
myself what did you have to forgive him
for he left
you you're old that no no no no no no
no you a
kid you're a
kid wasn't asking for forgiveness I was
forgiving him is what I mean to
communicate okay all right okay you were
you weren't gonna carry his crap anymore
no I was I it was for my own
freedom from that there you go okay all
right all right I got you all right all
right I didn't want to make it all about
this but I because we've had our we've
had our conversation we don't stay in
good consistent contact now but I put my
mom on the phone and I I let her because
she had to deal with my crap by herself
and so I put him on the phone and this
isn't where I wanted to head with I know
I know I
know but yeah I've I have released him
from that for my own sake okay you
you've let him go yeah
and you haven't dealt with
Salem right so you've done that work the
external work you let him go I'm not
carrying your bricks anymore you left me
you missed out on me and I hate that for
you because I'm a pretty good
guy and I'm a good man who serves I'm a
good man who strives I'm a good man who
works really hard on behalf of my
community in my country and my family
and you missed out on me I'm not
carrying that anymore
and here's the thing trauma's twofold my
brother and I know that word gets beat
to death especially in in the uh
military community and so I I don't want
to just sound like another yappy woo woo
guy but trauma is the thing that
happened to you Dad left
right and trauma's also the thing that
should have happened that
didn't so you've dealt with the thing
that did happen dead bailed
gone what I don't think you've dealt
with is turning to take a knee and
holding seven-year-old Salem in your his
face in both of your
hands and looking at him and saying I'm
so sorry what you went through
man I'll tell you my first step of my
freedom was writing my nine-year-old
self a
letter dear 9-year-old John is how I
started it I'm so sorry
and dude I sat in my basement with a
spiral notebook and a pen and I wept all
by
myself CU I didn't realize there was a
kid in there still asking himself what
did I do that was so
bad and here's the thing if you solve
that and I don't mean solve in a
mechanic militaristic kind of
way if you look in the mirror and say I
love that guy guy I love
me and you don't make your life about
yep I didn't make this I didn't make the
comms team I didn't make special units
team I didn't make any of these other
things it's just another another notch
of failure I couldn't even keep my dad
around much less make this team make
that team now my fiance isn't getting on
board I'm not even doing I'm not even
doing romance
right instead of that being the mod the
pair of glasses the model with which you
look at the
world you take those glasses on and put
on another set of glasses which are dude
I've been to Hell and
back and I'm still
here and I tried to fill it up with this
I try to fill it up with that I try to
fill it up with that bro there's nothing
to fill up
anymore and now you start looking at
personal development and looking at new
models and new theories and new ways of
doing the world and new ideas for
careers and jobs not to try to not feel
so crappy about who you see in the
mirror but because I love that guy and
he's worthy of having a great job and a
great career and work he loves he's
worthy of sitting down with the woman he
wants to marry and be like hey man let's
build something new I didn't have a good
model you probably didn't either let's
figure out something beautiful we can do
together right see what I'm saying I
think um the I think the issue with that
part is how to uh speak my fiance's
language and uh do it in such a way that
it U doesn't seem like an attack I feel
like what I'm I don't insult I don't
hurl uh abrasive words I think I'm just
kind of
generally Curt and the way that I
address things and I I try to like I I
want I think my my primary issue right
now is that I work too many hours and
it's not it's not your primary issue
brother your primary issue is you're
running I don't have
time to it's not it doing these other
things going it's not it fine Community
um the problem is you're running from
you and right now work is your
drug I I work this much in order to
survive and I want to not be working
this much I want to go back to school
okay I there are I want to launch this
business I've been you know
doing the groundwork for for the past
year and a half I I have these things I
have the rubric I have the
goals
um why do why do you want to do these
things why do you want to do them um
these are things about which I know I
have passion okay these are things
what's stopping you from going to get
it uh it's a it's a matter of timing and
planning the ex ution I can't like when
finances are involved I can't like right
now and I need to be working this much
in order to get by I'm trying to get out
of debt I'm trying I'm on baby step too
you know okay so here's what it sounds
like my body's breaking down because I
spent so much time breaking it down it
sounds like you're trying to do
everything all at the same
time yeah yeah and you're spread all
over the place you're trying to get
you're trying to get in shape trying to
start a business you're trying to start
a family you're trying to dig out of a
financial hole that you're in you're
trying to heal from childhood stuff
you're trying to do everything all the
same time yeah um be a good dad I think
I think all the stuff that
um my son's mom right now all the things
I've done throughout my whole life I
never had any passion for and then I
like I chose as a 10-year-old once I
finally decided that I I didn't believe
my dad was going to come come back um
once I stopped listening to the phone
calls as if it was true I uh that's when
I decided I wanted to be a father and a
good father and I've had that passion
that was the career goal that I never
changed uh I've gone through other there
I wanted to be a musician rock star I
wanted to do all the sports trainer all
these things throughout my life but I've
always wanted to be a father and this
one thing that I finally get to do
because I am a father my ex-wife is
gatekeeping um and
withholding uh custody
yeah and so uh just violation of the
parenting plan so there's all this stuff
that I got to do I have to do Court work
hold on hold on underneath all that is
your boy kind of going through what you
went through a little
bit he's young he's young than
um I don't think so okay because I do my
I do my best to be present but like I
know but you're that like I'm telling
you man you got to trust me on this this
that 9-year-old little boy inside of you
sees this whole thing starting over
again and he starts to sound the
alarms and those alarms get loud and
they get exhausting you know that and I
know
that and then you seek to solve it and
you're listening to all the right
podcasts you're listening to all the
right you're reading all the right
books Watching All the Right YouTube
shows and it says do everything all at
the same
time if you are trying to get a
successful business off the ground
you're going to miss some workouts
period Alex rosi talks is the most
honest person out in the space about all
that if you're going to get yourself
completely out of debt so you can have a
a firm Financial
Foundation you're going to miss some
activities with your kids because you
got to do a lot of
work but right now you're trying to do
everything all at the same time all of
it I think the greatest gift you could
give yourself is to go sit with somebody
and I know you roll your eyes I've been
doing enough counselors deloney I'm
tired of all
that I'm going to give you three months
to better help for free here's what I
want you to do I want you to sit down
with a list that you've already made
here's all the things I'm trying to do
right now at the same time get out of
debt start a business work 40 or 400
hours a week right be a good dad deal
with an ex-wife who won't let me be a
good dad deal with my fiance try to
learn a new way to talk to my fiance
because I'm Curt and exhausted and my
body's falling apart and by the way I
keep breaking down my body because I
watch a lot of videos on YouTube and say
that's the way to P strength and
whatever and I'm trying to read 50 books
a week and I'm trying and I want you to
ask for help help me pull these
apart because I need to do one or two of
these at the same time and that's it I'm
going to do them in order kind of like
paying your debts off man I'm just going
to pay this one
off and I'm going to go to the next one
I'm going to go to the next one when it
comes to your fiance being Curts okay
not everyone talks as much as I
do you my wife would love it if I was a
little more Curt I assure you that's not
the problem the problem is saying hey
honey I'm just a man a few words I love
you how can I love you
today not how can I fix you not how can
I make sure you're staying on your diet
plan or your workout plan or how many
books have you read today that's not it
how can I love you today
and if you have to quote unquote solve
something fix something be about solving
that question how can I love you today
man if you could just help with the
dishes if you could just on it got
it and let that be enough but I'm
telling you right now brother none of
that will be
enough until you let that nine-year-old
little boy of you that seven-year-old
little version of Salem who's still
sitting there in his bedroom wondering
why did my dad leave you've dealt with
that good for you I'm proud of you
man but now you got to turn and face
you most of the time that starts with a
series of letters dear seven-year-old me
when you write that letter I want you to
close your eyes and Visually go back to
being seven sometimes you have to sit
down on the floor to get that visual
like so your your ey line is is low I
want you to write that letter I'm so
sorry this happened man
wasn't your
fault dad was going through whatever dad
was going through and he left us and you
didn't deserve that
man thank you for holding the fort down
but I'm working on it now I got it from
here it's time for you to go play and
you may need to write a letter to
11-year-old you or 13-year-old you when
you started trying your first drinks and
they made everything a little bit better
or you smoke weed the first time or
whatever it is you've done to cope to
get to where you are right now
write a letter to the you that wanted so
badly to get into this military unit and
you didn't get
in let that guy off the hook man he gave
it his best shot he did he worked
hard and slowly what you'll be doing is
making peace with you
man because this sounds crazy to you but
you're worth being loved man you're
worth not leaving you're not the sum
total of the failures you have the
failures have built the foundation from
which you will do something
amazing but you got to stop
running love for yourself isn't
somewhere else it's right
here hang on the line brother I'm going
to send you both own your past change
your future and building an unanxious
life it's G be my gift to
you I got you man call
anytime please write those letters let
that boy go